cs go team heroic have begun legal
proceedings against their former coach
hunden after terminating his contract
now you might recognize his name from
the cs go coaching bug scandal
and it appears that once again hundred
may have found himself in
seriously hot water heroic have a list
of accusations against him but perhaps
the most shocking one of all is that he
shared confidential strategies with
heroic competitors
in the lead up to iem cologne
[Music]
all right then this isn't the first cs
go coaching scandal that we've covered
on this channel and
i'm pretty sure it won't be the last so
make sure you guys are subscribed to the
channel if you don't want to miss any
future videos
just like this one okay so i'm going to
start this story by reminding you guys
about the coaching bug scandal from
september 2020.
it was massive one of the biggest
scandals to rock cs go
essentially several coaches were using
the spectator tool
to reveal any part of a given map and
then relaying that incredibly important
information back to their teammates
we covered all of this at the time now
the bombshell at the heart of esl's
investigation
is the fact that they've proved coaches
from heroic
mibr and hard legion all use this
exploit at multiple different esl events
leading up to esl one cologne hundred
was one of three coaches to be initially
banned by the esl but by the end of the
month there were a total of 37
coaches from around the world that have
been banned or suspended for abusing the
bug in professional games
heroic suspended london as part of an
internal investigation while esl handed
him an eight-month ban from their
competitions
for two instances of the bug use hundred
then came clean about the whole thing
and said that his team knew
nothing about what he'd done while other
teams just straight up fired their
coaches heroic kept london although it's
safe to assume
there was a lot of work needed to
rebuild that trust and if that trust had
been repaired
well i wouldn't be sitting here talking
to you right now
because recently a new scandal focused
entirely around london
has crumbled any trust the two parties
have built back up
on july 29 2021 heroic posted a
statement explaining why london had
recently been removed from the org
iem cologne 2021 took place in mid-july
and heroic said they decided beforehand
that london would not be coaching the
team for it due to quote
severe trust issues although they didn't
explain where these trust issues came
from they allege that hunden retaliated
by blocking the team's access
to their internal strategy folder they
said that an internal investigation
had found that london had shared
confidential and
sensitive information from that strategy
folder with a
major competitor prior to the tournament
without their knowledge they said this
was a clear breach of contract and are
now pursuing a legal process in denmark
where
two courts have found sufficient grounds
for evidence collection
and they also said that hunden's
contract has been terminated
and if the allegations are true that is
perhaps the least surprising part of all
of this
the statement ended on a regretful tone
however with heroic saying they are
saddened by hundreds actions
the way that he let his teammates down
and that the relationship has ended this
way
it's an understandable feeling heroic
found themselves in the middle of the cs
go coaching bug scandal
perhaps one of the biggest cs go
scandals in recent memory
because of hunden's actions they could
have fired him
right then and there but they stuck with
him they gave him another chance
and if the allegations are true he blew
it big time
i mean let's be real he wasn't stealing
pencils from the office or
cutlery from the cafeteria he was
literally helping his competitors
in a competition hundred was quick to
address the allegations in a twitter
post titled regarding recent rumors
he started off by thanking heroic and
the players he got to work with before
saying that his leaving is a personal
decision
due to him coming to the realization
that he wants to begin a new chapter of
his life
he then addressed the allegations saying
recent rumors claim that i have
shared heroic stratbook this i can
categorically deny
i have the biggest respect for heroic
and i would never want to harm the team
or in any way
affect them negatively the material i
have shared is anti-strap material of
opponents
the material was shared with colleagues
from other teams in the context of
sparring
knowledge is essential for me as a coach
in respect to staying in the loop
and developing at no point in time has
heroic's own tactics been shared or
discussed
in addition to this i want to state that
i will always cooperate with esic
and other relevant institutions as well
as provide documentation about anything
found necessary to the case
so it sounds like a denial of heroic's
account
of what happened london is saying he
shared strategies for playing against
certain teams
with other teams now really this just
comes down to semantics
is your team strategy solely how you
play or is it also your knowledge of how
other teams play you could argue it's
both particularly in a game like
counter-strike where teams are known for
their strats
executes and playstyle so naturally it
will be part of
your strategy to counter theirs within a
few hours of hyundai's statement the
esports integrity commission known as
the esic
issued a statement on the matter for
quote the public's interest and to avoid
speculation
they said on tuesday 6th of july esic
received notification
that mr peterson that's hundred had
allegedly engaged in behavior
which could be classified as a breach of
esic's integrity program
the alleged behavior was related to
upcoming matches at iam cologne
upon receiving this notification esic
commenced an investigation reviewing the
evidence available
at the time and pursuing other
investigative lines of inquiry
they went on to say they had worked with
esl before iem cologne to see whether
hunden's actions had affected the
integrity of the tournament
they said that although hunden's actions
had breached their integrity program
his behavior had not impacted iem
cologne's competitive integrity
they ended their statement by saying
they will wait for any new evidence that
arises from the danish legal proceedings
they will then reassess whether there
has been any breaches to the integrity
program
and apply any appropriate sanctions
thereafter
perhaps the one thing that both parties
can agree on here is that this
knowledge sharing happened without the
consent of the rest of heroic's
management
and team and this mirrors the coaching
bug scandal in both cases
hundred alleges that his team didn't
know what he was up to
aside from all that if what hunden says
is true that he shared information
with other teams that could be a two-way
street
in heroic statement they make specific
reference to the information being
shared
with a key individual so perhaps they
too have evidence to bear
this all implies that at least one
member of another org
was engaging in the same behavior so
will the ongoing investigation and legal
proceedings uncover more of this
there's a lot of unanswered questions
here heroic said in their statement that
they have nothing more to add due to the
delicate nature of the situation
and unless hunden has anything more to
add himself then we'll need to do what
the esic and esl
are already doing and just wait for the
findings of the danish cause
it could take months but the full story
will undoubtedly surface one day the
question is now
how widespread does this thing go
for i want to say forks i feel like
that's funnier than
like someone who just steals forks
like they're good with spoons and knives
at home
right absolutely golden forks that's
what they go to work for
okay